- All right everybody.
Thank you for joining
us at re:Invent 2025.
It is exciting to see a full room today.
My name is Suraj Sajo,
I'm an AWS Customer Solutions Manager
working with our largest global
financial service customers
on their enterprise
transformation journey.
Welcome to Secure in Milliseconds
where you will learn about
how Visa built an AI
powered fraud defense on AWS
to secure account to account payments.
I'm joined today by Hema Zutshi,
Senior Director of Engineering at Visa
and Aravinda Nagalla, Chief Architect
for the Visa Protect A2A product at Visa.
It's a pleasure to have them here with me.
We've had a phenomenal
partnership over the years
and it is a testament to
their team's hard work
that we're able to share key
learnings from their journey.
Let's go ahead and get into the agenda.
First, I will talk about the
growing payments landscape,
focusing specifically on
account to account payments,
its increased relevance
and the growth and risk.
Then, my colleagues from
Visa will talk about
how they secure this
risk through Visa Protect
for account to account payments,
the high bar of requirements
that they held themselves to
and the journey in building this on AWS.
We will deep dive into how Visa
leveraged AWS Nitro Enclaves
to meet stringent security
requirements, achieve low latency
through Amazon EKS
optimizations and Memory DB
and built for a high bar of resilience.
We will then wrap up by
reflecting on the key takeaways
Visa had from their journey.
So in today's day and age,
consumers and businesses alike
are looking for
flexibility and convenience
when it comes to paying
for goods or services.
For years, the swipe of the
credit card had done the job.
For decades, this had been
the backbone of commerce
and it still continues
to play a critical role.
Then, we saw the rise
of the digital wallet.
All of a sudden with
the tap of your phone,
you can now pay for
your goods and services
in a seamless, contactless
checkout manner.
This was the next stage
in the payments evolution,
but with the rise of digital technology,
consumers and businesses
are looking for even more streamlined
cost optimal methods of payment.
This is where account to account payments
or A2A payments come into play.
A2A payments are secure,
reliable, streamlined,
instant payment method that
moves payments or funds
from the sender's bank account
directly to the recipient's
bank account without the need
for additional intermediaries
like credit card networks
or credit card instruments.
There's various use cases for A2A payments
like person to person, person to business,
business to person and beyond.
There are two types of A2A payments.
First is the push payment.
The push payment is
initiated by the sender
and moves funds directly from
the sender's bank account
to the recipient's bank account.
We've all probably used this.
A great example is let's
say a buddy of mine
covered me for lunch yesterday
and I need to pay him back.
I'll go ahead and send him a push payment.
The next is the pull payment.
The pull payment is
initiated by the recipient
and moves funds from the
sender's bank account
to the recipient's bank account.
Examples of this include a
business that has subscriptions
or recurring payments
that they would like to
receive from their clients
at a agreed upon time interval
and so they initiate a pull payment.
Let's go ahead and look at
how the A2A payment actually flows.
First, the consumer or
business requests the payment
and that request gets routed
to the sending financial
institution who then processes it
and initiates the payment via
a real-time payment network
or RTP network.
Few examples of RTP networks
include Pix in Brazil,
UPI in India, Faster Payments
in the UK and beyond.
The realtime payment network
then forwards the payment
to the receiving financial
institution who then processes it
and posts it to the receiver.
This more streamlined payment method
has seen increased
adoption over the years.
That is attributed primarily
due to the cost optimizations
available through RTP networks.
RTP networks are significantly
more cost efficient
than credit card networks.
Juniper Research is forecasting 83% growth
of the annual number of
transactions in the A2A landscape
by 2029, reaching 1 trillion
annual transactions.
By 2030, the annual transaction value
is expected to grow by
113%, reaching $195 trillion
of transactions annually.
That is tremendous scale
and tremendous growth.
But why does this matter?
Well, as A2A payments grow,
the transaction rates grow,
the transaction value grows,
so does the associated fraud.
Juniper research also
forecasts that the annual value
of fraud related losses is
expected to grow by 153%,
reaching $58 billion
worth of losses in the banking segment.
That is not a negligible amount
and this risk and this fraud
is exactly what customers
like Visa are solving for
by leveraging AWS while
meeting stringent requirements
around security, latency, resilience
and even data localization requirements
while enabling tremendous scale.
And so I invite my colleague Hema
to tell us how Visa secured
account to account payments
and built this on AWS.
- Thank you Suraj for
setting that context.
My name is Hema Zutshi.
I'm a Senior Director
of Engineering at Visa.
Visa is synonymous with trust
and to build that trust Visa
has invested over the years
in core principles around resilience,
high uptime, high availability,
stringent adherence to
cybersecurity and low latency.
And based on these principles
as Suraj was talking about
account to account payments,
growth of account to account payments,
wherever there is a
growth in the payments,
unfortunately fraud follows.
And since these account to
account payments do not use
the existing fraud payment
solutions of the card network,
Visa built a solution specifically
for non-card payments
called Visa Protect Account to Account,
which is aimed at enhancing the security
of non card payments.
It's designed to address the demand
of the greater security
in non card payments
and as Suraj was talking about,
it caters to all kinds of
non card payments B2B, B2C,
C2C and C2B.
To build this solution,
we leveraged the AWS infrastructure
and this infrastructure
allowed us to build
both our scoring engine,
which basically gives the fraud
score back to our customers
and they can make a decision on this
as well as our model
inferencing AIP platform,
which is our backbone for giving the score
back to our customers based
off the account models.
In Suraj's diagram earlier we talked about
account to account payments,
how when a sender receives,
sender send a payment
through its sending FI,
which is sender's Financial Institute,
it goes to RTP networks.
Here to avoid the fraud
between the two sender and receiver,
to avoid that kind of fraud,
we are introducing a call
made to Visa Protect Account to Account.
Here this call lets the sending
FI decide based off a score
that Visa Protect Account to Account
is going to return back.
To make a decision, if the score is high,
it can stop the payment
to go to the RTP network,
thus preventing the fraud from happening.
Now let's say for whatever reason,
if we are not able to make that call
to Visa Protect Account to Account
through the sending FI audit
did not get the high enough score.
There's another opportunity
for us at the receiving FI,
Receiving Financial Institute,
which is a receiver's bank
to make a call to Visa
Protect Account to Account
and stop the fraud from fully happening.
It can reject the payment
from the RTP network.
Visa builds solutions
for its global audiences
for all over various different regions.
Within various regions like UK,
the liability of fraud lies
both on sender and receiver.
So to protect both senders and receivers
from their liability of fraud,
Visa Protect Account to
Account is a solution
that a lot of our customers are using
to prevent fraud from happening.
In the next few slides,
I will be talking about
the requirements that we
had to build this solution
and how did we leverage AWS platform
for building this solution.
Visa has traditionally built its solutions
within its on-prem systems
so a lot of our requirements
were catered towards our
on-prem data centers.
We had to rethink some of that
and make sure we are able to build it
as per the same guidance
as we are building
to protect our customer
data in the on-prem systems.
So the first requirement
is adherence to very stringent
cybersecurity guidelines.
This is not just a buzzword for Visa.
In Visa, this is taken
very, very seriously
because our customers trust
us with their PII information
and with their PII data.
So on top of your regular DSRs,
which is design security requirements
and technical security requirements
and everything that comes
with data protection,
we had a unique problem to solve
as we were taking our solution into cloud,
which was to protect against
in-memory data exposure.
Data is encrypted, protected
when it is in transit
or when it is stored.
It is not protected however,
when it is getting processed in memory
and it is these times that
various threat vectors
and malicious agents
try and steal the sensitive data.
Threat vectors like core
dump and swap files,
exposed data endpoints
and memory scraping hardware,
this is the chance where they,
they can get into the cloud network
and steal customer information.
To protect against that,
not only did we build
another layer of security,
we rethought the architecture.
We went our solution against this threat
was to go with zero trust architecture
and use AWS Nitro Enclaves.
Think about Nitro Enclaves
as a secure vault within a main server
and nobody has access to that secure vault
and all communication to that secure vault
happens through the main
server on a secure channel
and nobody, not even AWS or VISA accounts
have access to that.
My colleague Aravinda is
gonna deep dive on this
in next few segments.
Next very important requirement
to build a solution that
caters to all the regions
that we support is to adhere
to the local regional requirements.
Since we were building this solution
for our European markets,
one of the very important
requirements for us
was to build around GDPR requirements.
Even though GDPR does not
necessarily request you
to have data localized, we are able to
do better with their requirements
if the data is localized.
We also had requirements from our banks
or our customers to keep data locally.
For that specific reason,
our solution to build the
solution to this platform
was to use AWS regions
for both transactional and
model inferencing engines
to be hosted in the
European regions in AWS.
And this not only helped us
with the localization
requirement, this also helps us
with the next requirement
which is around low latency.
Again, low latency is not just,
we don't take it lightly,
it's a very, very serious requirement
in the financial sector.
Transactions happen within few seconds
and any kind of latency
can break the overall user experience.
Take for example,
let's talk about the
example that Suraj took
where two friends are splitting the bill.
Now that is happening
over the RTP networks.
If we now want to add another
layer to it of security
by using Visa Protect Account to Account,
we cannot afford to extend that time
of end-to-end transaction
between these two
because that will break
the overall experience.
To make sure
that we are able to provide
this fraud solution,
we had to make sure the
solution that we are building
is able to give the end-to-end results
in less than 250 milliseconds,
that is a fraction of a second.
Which means that you have
to accept the transaction,
process it, run it through our models
and respond back within 250 milliseconds.
To solution this, we looked
at two different approaches.
One was co-localization,
which is what I talked
about in the previous slide,
where to avoid any kind
of network latency,
any time we are trying to
create a TLS connection,
it goes back and forth a few times.
That takes time to establish.
To avoid that latency,
we made sure that we build our solutions
within the local regions
and we also architected
our solution based off
Amazon Memory DB with Valkey.
Now this is a very interesting solution
because not only does Amazon Memory DB
gives us faster reads,
but it also gives us durability of data,
which is the right combination
to be used in a financial solution
which basically gives us the
faster read time of a cache
and durability of a database.
Aravinda will talk in detail about this.
We also used a lot of TLS
connection pooling mechanisms
to help be able to give us
the 250 milliseconds latency
that Aravinda will be covering as well.
The last business requirement
that I want to talk about
is around resiliency
and high availability.
One of the principles for our
trust are high availability,
resilience and uptime.
Within Visa, there is a categorization
within tiers for our applications,
anything that is transactional
will be considered a tier RT
or a tier zero and to be
able to consider a tier RT
or a tier zero,
one needs to be able to fulfill
at least 99.99% of uptime.
Think about this uptime that
within this an entire year,
application can only go down,
it cannot go down for more
than 52 minutes, 35 seconds.
Beyond that, we will be breaking our SLAs.
There is another important requirement
that we had to cater to.
Within Visa we have our internal
availability disaster
recovery requirements,
which we call ITDR
and to cater to those ITDRs,
we have to build redundancy
in at least dual regions
and within that redundancy,
the regions have to be
more than 60 miles apart.
So to build our solution
to cater to our tier zero
uptime requirements of 99.99,
our solution was to build our
application within two regions
and give them redundancy both in London
and Ireland region with a multi AZ setup,
we are using three AZs,
availability zones within AWS setup.
So this was all about various requirements
that we had to build around.
I'll spend some time talking about
the functional architecture
of Visa Protect Account to Account
and then Aravinda will go into the details
of the architecture.
So Visa Protect Account to
Account is a scoring engine
which basically takes a request
and processes it, runs
it through our models
and gives a score back
to the end customers.
To enable this, we have
two important components,
we have the real time
component which has scoring API
as well as the model inferencing API.
Here, the scoring API talks
to our external clients,
it does all the data processing,
it does all the data
acceptance, security checks,
everything and then decides to,
through a decision service
decides to call the right model
for its inferencing.
Within model inferencing we
have aggregation service,
we have orchestration service,
we have long-term profiles
that run and are able to provide a score,
a risk score for a transaction.
Along with the real time system
which is the core of our platform,
we also have a near real
time offline system,
which uses a scoring API
as well as a feature engineering platform.
Scoring API is an important offline system
which accepts daily files
where daily status files, it accepts the,
It has data consumers that
accepts data from our clients.
It also, any time we are
onboarding a new client,
this is another system that
allows us to get historical data
of the clients and we are
able to build our features
based off that data.
Our feature engineering components
has both longtime profile generation
and short time profile generation features
along with your billing, reporting
and all other components
that comprise a system.
So with that, I'll hand
it over to Aravinda
who will be going deep
on the architecture.
- Thanks Hema.
Hello everyone, my name
is Aravinda Nagalla,
I'm a Solution Architect at Visa.
Next I'll walk through
the technical architecture
for the functional components
that Hema just described.
Later, we will dive deep
into some of the AWS technologies
we used in our architecture.
Let's start by looking closely
at our realtime scoring API workload.
This is the REST API that our clients use
to get their score from our model.
Client requests land in our DMZ VPC.
Think of this as a secure
perimeter facing the internet
where each incoming packet
is inspected by Amazon network firewall
and only the traffic from
white-listed IP addresses
is allowed inside.
Then the request lands
at our load balancer
where we authenticate the
request using mutual TLS.
Successfully authenticated request
travel via transit gateway, VPC endpoints
and then land at our Amazon API gateway,
which is hosted in private spoke VPC.
API Gateway enforces usage plans,
applies throttling per client
and then sends it to the
A2A a gateway application running
inside the Nitro Enclaves
via a network load balancer.
A2A gateway application
receives the request,
terminates the TLS
connection inside the enclave
and then performs some validations
and it also does the
secondary authentication
using token validation
and then it encrypts
the sensitive PIA data
using KMS encryption.
Then it converts the REST
request into GRPC protocol
and then it sends it to our
downstream decision service application.
The decision service runs
on top of Amazon EKS,
it transforms the incoming request
and then it does the duplicate check
by doing lookups into Amazon
ElastiCache for Valkey.
It also does the enrichment
of the incoming payload
by doing some lookups into
the ElastiCache as well.
Then it calls our model
inferencing platform.
Our model inferencing
platform runs on Ray cluster,
which is deployed on top of Amazon EKS.
Model inferencing
mainly consists of three
different services.
LT profile service is fetching
the long term profile features
from Amazon Memory DB.
Aggregation service
performs real time
aggregations by fetching
short term profile features
from the Memory DB as well.
Once the features are ready,
AIas serve runs the model
and generates the risk score.
The score is then sent back
to the decision service
where we have a rule
engine applying the rules
and then transforming the
response by decisioning.
Then, it sends that
response back to the gateway
where we convert the GRPC response to REST
and then that response is
sent back to the client.
So that completes the real time flow.
Both the model inferencing service
and the decisions and the gateway service
are writing to, writing
the request and responses
to Amazon managed streaming for Kafka,
which is fed to our
downstream applications
such as reporting, billing,
and near realtime feature
engineering processes.
So we chose ElastiCache for Valkey
and Memory DB with Valkey Engine
because they provide about 20%,
they're about 20% cheaper than Redis
and they provide the same functionality
and performance as well.
Our applications didn't need to change
because the Redis client libraries work
as is with the Valkey engine.
That's on the realtime side.
Next, let's take a look at
our offline flow pipeline.
This flow enables our
clients to upload daily files
such as entitlements, fraud data
and bank to bank account data
and transaction status files.
This is also used by our clients
to upload one time historical
transactional data,
which gets used for model training
and baseline feature generation.
Clients connect to AWS
transfer family service
running again inside the DMZ VPC,
which is facing the internet
and they upload the PGP encrypted files
using SFTP protocol.
The files land in an S3 bucket
from where we have a scan
process picking up these files
and running AWS GuardDuty
scanning for malware detection.
The successfully scanned files
get moved to another S3 bucket
and an SNS notification is also generated.
This SNS notification
is consumed by our data ingestion process,
which is also running
inside the Nitro Enclaves.
It consumes the notification
and then it picks up the file
that was successfully scanned
and it pulls that file into
the Nitro Enclave memory
and it decrypts the file
inside the Nitro Enclave.
Then it passes the file
and it performs various
checks, validations,
and then it starts
encrypting the PIA data,
which is in each record.
The encrypted records
are written to Amazon
Managed Streaming for Kafka
and the file level
metadata is also stored in
Amazon Aurora DB for reporting purposes.
The Kafka data return
is consumed by various applications.
We use Amazon Data Firehose for
consuming the data from Kafka
and writing into an S3 bucket.
From there we have EMR jobs
picking up these data files
and then aggregating
and then writing it a separate S3 bucket.
This S3 data gets used by our
downstream feature engineering
and model validation and
model retraining purposes.
We also have another consumer application
which reads from topics
such as entitlement
and branch code data
and then writing that data
into Amazon ElastiCache for Valkey.
This Valkey data
is used by our real time
scoring API workload.
The same data is used is
written to Amazon Aurora DB
for long-term storage.
This ensures that both
our real time pipeline
and offline pipeline use secure, validated
and enriched data,
share that data across the both flows.
Next, let's dive deep
into AWS Nitro Enclaves,
the security backbone for our
sensitive data processing.
So the Nitro Enclaves
are the secure, hardened
and isolated environments
running inside the EC2 instances.
They have no external
connectivity, no SSH access
and no persistent storage.
Not even the root user from parent EC2
can log into the enclave.
Only the parent EC2 can
connect to the enclave
using a secure local
channel via Visa protocol.
These are ideal for
processing sensitive data
such as bank account
numbers, credit card numbers,
and customer data.
Our A2A gateway application
runs inside the Nitro Enclave,
this is the technical
design for our application.
During the startup,
the application connects
to secrets manager
and KMS proxy via proxies
and fetches the envelope encrypted
data encryption key into the enclave.
Then it decrypts the encrypted key
using KMS customer managed key
and then it caches that
key in the enclave memory.
When an input scoring request arrives,
the NLB sends it to the gateway proxy
running on the parent EC2.
From the proxy converts the
incoming TCP protocol request
into Visa protocol and
sends it into the enclave.
Inside the enclave,
A2A gateway application
receives the request,
terminates the TLS connection,
and then it validates the payload
and then it starts encrypting
the plain text PIA data
using the cached deck that
was cached during the startup.
Then it sends the,
it converts the request from REST to GRPC
and then it sends that request
to downstream decision service application
proxying via visa channel again.
This ensures that the
sensitive data processing
is entirely happening
inside the Nitro Enclave
without exposing it to the
in memory exposure threats
that Hema talked about earlier.
These are some of the
best practices we follow
for our application deployment
inside the Nitro Enclaves.
The enclave resource allocation
is done using this allocated .YAML file.
We declare the vCPUs
and memory inside this YAML configuration
and the best practice to do
this is using user data scripts.
Because Nitro Enclaves requires
contiguous huge pages memory,
if the allocation or
reservation is not done
during the start-up,
the memory can get fragmented
and it may not be available
for enclave to reserve.
So in order to avoid
that, we do the allocation
with the user data scripts.
Next is careful tuning
of proxies is a must
because this provides a better throughput.
Otherwise we may not get
the throughput that we require.
So we use Socat proxies for converting the
TCP to VSOC and vice versa.
And Socat has options for
concurrent connections
such as reuse, address and fork.
So by carefully tuning them,
we were able to achieve better throughput.
Next is health check endpoints,
should check the health of the application
as well as proxies.
So in order to make sure
that the instance is healthy
before sending the traffic
to a particular instance.
As we saw earlier, the
application inside the enclave
fetches the encryption
keys during the startup
and then caches them into the memory
so that it avoids latency
in getting the keys
for every request.
So by using all these optimizations,
we were able to achieve
around 150 to 200 TPS
throughput with a single M5A
2x large EC2 instance.
So performance is just as critical
as security for our application.
Next, let's take a look at
how we optimize for latency.
We use TLS 1.3 and HTTP
2.0 throughout our stack
for faster handshakes because
TLS 1.3 is one less round trip
and HTTP 2.0 provides
multiplex connections.
Both, I mean AWS load balancers
do support both of these
and even our applications support them.
We recommend our clients also
to use TLS 1.3 and HTTP 2.0
because it provides
better end-to-end latency
and throughput.
And this is also highly secure as well.
On the Amazon API gateway
for the ingress traffic,
we use VPC endpoints and
for the backend integration
with our A2A gateway
application, we use VPC link.
So this ensures that the
traffic stays entirely on the
Amazon backbone network,
giving us consistent
low latency performance.
So on the NLB for client routing policy,
AZ affinity setting is enabled.
This means that the client,
the traffic stays within the AZ
where client is making the request from.
This provides better latency as well.
And for the load balancer,
target selection policy
cross zone load balancing is enabled
in order to provide the high availability.
And the application gateway, which we,
which is running inside the enclave,
as we saw earlier,
the secrets and keys are
fetched during the startup
and cached in the memory
and we do have background
threads refreshing these keys
as and when needed.
This avoids repeated fetch latencies.
Next, let's take a look
at how we fine tune EKS
for both performance and resiliency.
So we use AWS load balancer controller
to provision and manage load balancers.
So load balancer controller provisions
ALB for Kubernetes ingress resource
and NLB for Kubernetes
load balancer resource.
NLB can be provisioned
with either instance
or IP target type.
And so the annotation that we see here,
AWS Load Balancer NLB target type
is set to IP which means
the parts gets IP addresses
directly assigned from Amazon VPC subnets,
avoiding any extra network hops
and providing better performance.
Next, let's look at pod scheduling.
There are mainly three ways
we can control the pod scheduling:
NodeAffinity, this addresses
whether you want to place
a particular pod on a node
with a specific characteristic.
For example, a hardware
characteristic like
enclave enablement.
So for example, we are
now migrating our A2A
gateway application from EC2 to EKS
and this application pod
needs to run on the nodes
where enclaves are enabled.
So this is done by using the NodeAffinity.
PodAffinity and PodAntiAffinity,
when the placement of a pod
depends on the location of other pods,
PodAffinity can be used to
co-locate synergistic workloads.
For example, if we have a web server
and a corresponding caching pod,
they can be co-located
together using PodAffinity.
PodAntiAffinity, this distributes the pods
across a failure domain,
providing high availability.
For example, if you declare a
service with three replicas,
you don't want all of them
to stay within the same AZ,
so this can be controlled
by using PodAntiAffinity.
Next is TopologySpreadConstraints.
When you want to ensure
that the replicas from a pod
for a single service are evenly balanced
across the different failure domains,
that's when we use the
topology spread constraints.
Next we will see how we
can define some of these.
This is a sample manifest
definition for topology spread.
The section topology spread constraints,
this ensures that the replicas
are evenly distributed
across the failure domain.
Max Q is set to one.
This is a crucial setting,
this dictates that the number
of pods for a given service
in a given AZ will not
differ by more than one
with the number of pods in other AZs.
And the topology key is set to zone,
which means that the failure domain
that we talked about earlier
is at availability zone level.
Next is topology aware routing.
This keeps the network traffic
within the AZ where it originated.
This helps with the reliability
performance and cost
because cross zone traffic is charged.
So this is a sample definition
for topology aware routing.
We have the service definition
under which we have the metadata section
and we are setting the topology
mode annotation with auto.
This auto mode tells Kubernetes
to keep the network
traffic within the same AZ
where it originated.
It also has a smart default.
If there are no healthy parts
available within that AZ,
it'll automatically reroute
to the available parts
in other AZs.
This feature works by adding
hints to endpoint slices.
In order for the routing
algorithm to work effectively,
it is recommended that we
have at least three replicas
running in a given AZ.
For example, if we have a service with the
nine replicas defined
for within three AZs,
this definition will make sure
that there are three parts per each AZ.
So combining all these
optimizations together
and using Amazon ElastiCache
for Valkey and Memory DB
in our realtime scoring API workload,
we were able to achieve our
latency OLF 250 milliseconds.
In fact, our P 99.5
latencies are much better,
about 40% lower than that
and we were able to
successfully test our surveys
with the bursts of up to a thousand TPS.
Next, let's take a look
at our multi-region
Active-active architecture,
which is essential for
a tier zero application
such as VP A2A per
visa's ITDR requirements.
So we have CloudFlare
Akamai DNS routing traffic
to the nearest region
and in each region, we have both compute
and data services
deployed across three AZs.
Load balancer is distributing the traffic
across these three AZs.
We have the application
layer writing to ElastiCache
in local as well as remote region
for our realtime duplicate checks.
And Amazon managed
streaming for Kafka MSK data
is replicated using MSK replicator.
This is used by our near realtime
feature engineering flows.
S3 cross region replication
is enabled for our
offline flow pipe buckets
and we use Amazon Aurora DB in
our file processing pipelines
and Aurora DB replication
is enabled from primary to,
primary to secondary.
Using our AWS MSK replicator
and S3 cross region replication
and Aurora Global DB replication
reduces the operational
complexity on our side
because AWS takes care of
the replication overhead.
So this gives us high availability,
disaster resilience and
consistent performance globally.
That's about as deep as we'll go
on the technical side today.
Next I invite Hema back
to the stage to wrap up.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you Aravinda for the
detailed architecture overview.
I would spend a few
minutes just to talk about
the key takeaways of our
partnership with AWS team
and what did we learn as part
of building the solution,
Visa Protect Account to Account.
This is for the first time actually
we took something internally
and tried to take it to cloud.
Visa has spent a lot of time and effort
to build its hybrid cloud solution
and our application was one
of the very first applications
that decided to go and use
that hybrid cloud solution
and host an application on
that hybrid cloud solution.
As part of this journey, what we built
and Aravinda did talk
about that was a solution
that caters to Visa's
stringent operational
and cybersecurity guidance
is something that we
follow very religiously
on our on-prem system,
but to see how that is
gonna work on a hybrid cloud
and to take that with a thousand TPS
with 99.99 availability,
with a fraction of second latency.
This we consider as a
blueprint for our application
and we were able to take
this, it's fully functional,
our clients are using
the scoring service today
in our UK region.
Now, the next part of
this journey was to see
how do we use this blueprint
and take it to various other regions.
As I talked about Visa
being a global company,
a lot of our solutions are
built for our global markets
to cater to their local requirements.
We are using this blueprint
that we have built
and kind of on top of that
using the IAC scripts and all
to go faster to other
regions with slight tweaks
that are needed for those regions.
As an example, I will talk about
Visa's foray into the
South American markets
with Brazil being one of our clients
where we are taking this
solution to Sao Paulo region
and opening it up for our markets,
the Visa Protect Account
to Account solution to help
protect and prevent fraud,
account to account fraud there.
The third important part
that I want to talk about
is our partnership with the
AWS team, Suraj and team.
We've worked for past two and a half years
in trying to build this solution
with various other partners within Visa,
with our operations team,
with our cybersecurity team,
and it has been a great partnership.
We have all evolved, we have
learned with experiences
and we have leveraged a lot
of different AWS patterns
that has helped us scale our
services and our solution.
With that, I would like to end
this presentation for here.
I would like to thank
you all for coming here
and listening to us.
And if you guys have any questions,
we are happy to have side
conversations on the site.
But thank you all for your time.
I would love for all you
to fill in the survey
in the mobile apps, thank you.
(audience applauds)